Congressman Jim Jordan,
so-called government
weaponization committee
devolving into chaos.
The chairman clashing
with Democrats in a hearing today
as some of the key
witnesses in his crusade against the DOJ
and the FBI faced
serious questions about their credibility
Mr.
Chairman,
these individuals have been determined
not to be whistleblowers.
These are not whistleblowers.
They've been determined by the agency
not to be whistleblowers.
Are you deciding that
they're whistleblowers?
Yes, the Lord decides.
Did you not listen to Mr.
Levitt's testimony?
Do you not read the law?
The lawyer needs it.
They already
his attorney isn't recognizing was a lady
Summer is OUTFRONT with more on
the serious questions
surrounding Jordan's star witnesses.
To FBI
employees who were stripped
of their security clearances.
This is the kind of retaliation
they face for coming forward
and telling us the truth.
Now, star witnesses for Republicans
as the House
Judiciary Subcommittee tries
to drive home
the GOP narrative
that the FBI is unfairly
targeting
conservatives, activists in the FBI
and the Department of Justice
have weaponized
the full weight
of their agencies
against everyday Americans.
Democrats slammed the premise
of the hearing
My colleagues on the far right
are on a mission to attack, discredit
and ultimately dismantle
the FBI and question
the credibility of Republicans,
so-called whistleblowers.
You all have employment grievances.
That doesn't make you whistleblowers.
The enumeration of grievances
does not constitute whistleblowers.
At us.
The hearing comes a day
after the FBI said in a letter
that certain FBI employees
had their security clearances revoked
after espousing
alternate theories
about the January
six attack on the Capitol.
The witnesses claim that's retaliation.
It appears that I was retaliated against
because I forwarded information
to my superiors and others
that questioned the official narrative
of the events of January 6th.
Among the reasons
FBI staff operations specialist
Marcus Allen had
his security clearance pulled
trying to hinder investigations
into January six writers.
The FBI wrote
the claim that he obstructed
a lawful investigation is dubious,
and I do not recall ever being admonished
for such an infraction.
His clearance was first suspended
in January.
20, 22, according to the FBI.
In one
email, Allen told colleagues
to exercise extreme
caution and discretion
in pursuit
of any investigative inquiries
or leads pertaining
to the events of January six.
He also suggested
federal law enforcement
infiltrated the January six crowd.
The committee
also heard today from former FBI
agent Steve Fred.
His clearance was suspended
in September 2022 and later revoked
The FBI says
friend objected to a SWAT team arrest
of a January six rioter
use an unauthorized flash
drive to download documents
from FBI computer systems
and participated
in unauthorized media interviews.
My whistleblowing was apolitical
and in the spirit of upholding my oath.
Nonetheless, the FBI
cynically elected
to close ranks and attack the messenger.
Republicans also featured FBI
Special Agent Garrett O'Boyle,
who says he expressed concern
about wrongdoing in the FBI
only to see his security clearance
suspended.
That suspension
which began in September 2022,
is still under review.
Mr.
O'Boyle,
why do you think they came down on you
so darn hard?
The agency
as a whole wants to get rid of people
who simply just don't
hold the line that they want
Now, Republicans are using
these witnesses
to try to drive home
this idea to Americans,
this sort of dubious claim that the FBI,
which of course, is known
for being a pretty conservative
law enforcement
body, is actually full of liberals
who are targeting conservatives
across the country.
And, Aaron, we've heard Jim
Jordan is committed to this
so-called weaponization
of federal government
and pushing that forward, this Congress.
So you can bet
this is not going
to be the last hearing on this subject.
Well, that is for sure.
All right. Thank you, as always, Sarah.